the increase in choices that we got with
cable television was huge
in terms of its effect on storytelling
and its effect on the quality of
storytelling that happened in in the TV
medium versus filmed with all of this
choice this explosion of choice there
was a huge downside which was that it
fragmented the audience and that meant
that that the normal economic model of
how TV worked and how it would be
consumed no longer work that way and so
the for example the number of people in
the audience for any show on network
started to fall and fall radically now
the upside of it was that with all this
extra choice the need to write a show
that appeal to the lowest common
denominator
ie the biggest number of possible people
that we can get to watch our show that
changed and now we could create a show
that would appeal to a smaller segment
still influential segment of the
audience but a much smaller segment and
so you get a show like Mad Men on AMC
which has maybe 3 million 3 million
viewers per episode that that's that's
peanuts in network and yet this show has
tremendous influence and the the people
who watch Mad Men who love Mad Men are
people that the the sponsors want to get
to but what that also meant then was
that if we don't have to try to appeal
to everybody with again the idea that
it's the lowest common denominator we
don't we don't want to speak above
people and so there was the tendency to
dumb down the story the reverse occurred
which was
for this audience let's make the most
challenging story possible it also meant
because the way cable worked especially
pay cable it was all about let's come up
with a show that will appeal to our
subscribers not to the largest audience
and so the freedom to do something
really unique and different was there
for the creators and that's also where
we started to get the serials coming in
and so on so all of these these things
work together to come up with a number
of shows now that are as good as we've
ever had in television we are now in the
golden age of television and a good
reason for that is because of the
presence of cable and how that allowed
us to do a lot more
genres and tell stories in to a much
more focused audience so we've got a
cable channel like AMC that can generate
three of the best shows that I've ever
been on television in Breaking Bad Mad
Men and Walking Dead each in their own
unique genre not possible on network why
was there a tendency to dumb down the
content how the actors sort of relate
their message to the audience why is it
now so I think it was again one of those
pieces of conventional wisdom which are
oftentimes wrong just as the idea that
oh you have to have likeable characters
which was proven wrong the idea that you
have to write down to the audience was
proven wrong against Seinfeld was a big
step in that direction
the the perception was that in order to
get the biggest possible audience and
remember were in the old days we're
talking 30 million people to watch every
week that show that's a lot of people
and so the idea was
we can't do these huge differences in
terms of either intelligence or in terms
of where we take the characters the
highs and lows and so on the complexity
of how we have these characters interact
we can't do any of that stuff if we're
trying to get 30 million people a week
that that at least was the perception of
it and there may be some truth to it
because there is no cable show that gets
30 million people a week not even close
but the the point is that when you
didn't no longer have that requirement
from above which was you've got to
appeal to this many people then it was
how do we tell the best story we can
tell now another key feature is that
over the years writers have taken total
control of the medium and in my view
this is the single most important reason
why the writing in television is better
than any other medium in American
entertainment writers have control the
medium not directors not producers not
movie stars and the result is plain for
everybody to see it used to be that film
was thought as the little brother they
you know oh well if you can't make it in
film well you can maybe try television
well that's completely flipped now and
again it's because of this fracture
audience film still they're trying to
appeal to a worldwide audience that's
even bigger than 30 million people
they're trying to get people all over
the world which is why the differences
of what we see in film are now the
narrowest it's ever been would basically
have out of Hollywood superhero movies
that's it yeah at Oscar time you'll get
maybe the five films that Hollywood made
that year that are dramas that are
serious works of art that we then get to
nominate for best
picture and then everybody forgets that
for the whole you know other 11 and a
half months of the year they're putting
out superhero movies comic book hero
movies that's because that's that that's
that story form that genre which is
essentially myth plus action appeals to
the largest number of people in various
cultures around the world TV doesn't
have their requirements so it can do
things as different is Breaking Bad Game
of Thrones Downton Abbey The Good Wife
and so on and the quality within those
genres on TV is so high if you look at
say the nine major TV genres you could
argue that on seven of those nine we
have the best show of that genre right
now on that we've ever had that's
phenomenal
you